يجتمع مجددا في صيغه مجموعه
بوخارست التي اطلقتها في عام 2015 مع
الرئيس دوده
بمناسبه
عوده الحربي الى اوروبا هذه الحرب التي
جلبت المعاناه
والبؤس والقتل ونزوح الملايين من
الاوكرانيين ودمار غير مسبوق وغموض كبير
نحن قاده الجناحه الشرقي علينا مسؤوليه
الوقوف معا للدفاع عن امننا
وسلام يجب ان نواصل الوفاء بالتزاماتنا
لدعم اوكرانيا
طالما احتاجت لذلك
الانتصار في هذه الحرب هذا ما ستواصل
القيام به ونحن لسنا بمفردنا
جهودنا هي في اطار الاتحاد او حلف الاطلسي
وارحب اليوم بحضور الرئيس جوزيف بايدن
وهذا يعيد تاكيد على جوهر صيغه بوخارست
وكذلك
التزام الاداره الامريكيه تجاه امن الجناح
الشرقي للحلف
ان هذا الالتزام قوي للغايه ويتطلع الى
المستقبل من خلال زياده الوجود العسكري
الامريكي
والاستعداد الاستراتيجيه امريكيه للبحر
الاسود ارحب ايضا
بمشاركه امين عام النيتو يانس ستولتنبر
لاغراض التنسيق وقبل نحو عام حاولت روسيا
تدمير الانف في اوروبا
النظام الدولي القائم على القواعد وروسيا
تتصرف
بلد معتدي وقد شهدنا ذلك في جمهوريه
مولدوفا وفي جورجيا وكذلك في اوكرانيا
ذاتها
اليوم هؤلاء شركاء يستفيدون من دعم الحلف
للقدره على الصمود على المدى البعيد وهذا
ضروري حتى يحققوا سلاما واستقرار وازدهار
مستديما نحن ندعم بقوه ايضا
المنظوره الاوكراني الاوروبي الاطلسي
لدمان ان يكون او تكون هذه الحرب هي اخر
ما تقوم به روسيا وحتى تؤدي الى ردع اي
عدوان وتقلص هذا الهجوم وحلف النيت يقف
قويا ويظهر التزام واضحا تجاه اوكرانيا
وشعبها ان هذه المجموعه اقوى من اي وقت
مضى وتطلع لمواصله
تنسيق فيما بيننا باتجاه قمه اطلع السيا
ناجحه في مدينه فيليو شكرا جزيلا لكم شكرا
جزيلا
فخامه الرئيس واعطي الكلمه الان الى
المضيف الثاني للقمه
السيده سوزانا رئيسه سلوفاكيا شكرا
السيد الرئيس دوده الرئيس با الامين العام
للحلف ايها الحلفاء الاعزاء كما شرت السيد
الرئيس نلتقي اليوم في اوقات خاصه
تصادف الذكرى الاولى لعدوان روسيا على
اوكرانيا
هذا العام جعلنا اقوى واكثر وحده نحن
البلدان في الجناح الشرقي نحظ بحمايه اكبر
من اي وقت مضى ومعا نجحنا في اختبار
التضامن والانسانيه من خلال دعمنا
لاوكرانيا الرئيس بايدن حضوركم اليوم دليل
اخر بان وحدتنا الاطلسيه اقوى من اي وقت
مضى وهي فرصه تسمح لنا بمناقشه توقعاتنا
من قمه النيتو في فيديو على سبيل المثال
كيف يمكن ان نضم ان يكون هناك اي اماكن
رماديه في دفاعنا كيف يمكن ان اقلم دفاعنا
او انفاقنا الدفاع بشانه بيئتنا الامنيه
وكيف يمكن نضمن قدره اوكرانيا على الدفاع
النفسيه طالما احتاج لذلك كيف يمكن ان
نتحرك او نعزز العلاقات بين النيتو وروسيا
هذا نناقشه اليوم وكذلك في قمه
براتيسلافيا في يونيو في فيديو يوسفي
يوليو اشكركم فخامه رئيس دوده على
استضافتنا واتطلع لمناقشاتنا شكرا شكرا
فخامه الرئيسه اصحاب الفخامه الاصدقاء
الاعزاء نحن سعداء جدا ان يكون بيننا
اليوم ضيف خاص
قبل الدعوه الى قمه رئيس الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه السيد جوزيف بايدن اهلا وسهلا
بك سيدي واعطيك الكلمه شكرا جزيلا لكم
شكرا جزيلا وانا سعيد ان اتواجد هنا قد
تتذكرون
قبل سنوات
عندما كنا نوسع النيتو
وسخريه القدر هي انه
ما تذكره
فيما يخص صديقنا في روسيا
هو انني قلت لها انك تطالب دائما
لفلدت النيت
وسوف تحصل على انضمام في لندن الى النيت
ماذا حدث
فنحن اقوى مما كنا عليه
وقلت
ليقول لي الرؤساء اننا هنا معكم
كحلفاء اقوياء في النيت
والامين العام برايي انجز عملا رائعا
لفتره طويله واعول على حكمه كثيرا ان
مجموعه الدول التسعه انشات في عام 2015
ليس بالنسبه لاوكرانيا فحسب ولكن لحريه
الديمقراطيات في اوروبا والعالم
وقد تحدثت عن هذا الامر مع الرئيس لينسكي
عندما زرت كيف قبل يومين والقاده
المجتمعون حول هذه الطاوله اكدوا التزامنا
المشترك تجاه كل هذه القيم وقدمنا مساعده
امنيه حاسمه لاوكرانيا ودعم حاسم للملايين
من اللاجئين وضامنهم حصول اوكرانيا او
الاوكرانيين على الخدمات الاساسيه ومعا
سنواصل تقديم الدعم لاوكرانيا بينما تدافع
عن حريتها خلال العام المنصر
بفضل تقديمكم لدور ريادي عززنا ايضا
النيتو والتزام الولايات المتحده والنيت
وقلت ذلك لكم مرارا وتكرار واكرر ذلك الان
هذا واضح كل وضوح
الماده الخامسه هي التزام مقدس بالنسبه
للالويه المتحده سوف ندافع عن كل شبر من
اراضي الدول النيت وفي هذه اللحظه المهمه
تطلع
لمناقشاتنا والخطوات اللاحقه التي سوف
نتخذها لابقاء حلفنا قوي لردع اي عدوان
اخر ما هو علم بحق ليست اوكرانيا وانما
الحريه
وفكره انها اكثر من الف عنصر
يهاجمون بلد بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه
الامور تغيرت بشكل جذري وعلينا ان نتاكد
من اننا نتصدى لذلك شكرا جزيلا لكم على
دعوه وتطلعوا لمناقشاتنا
شكرا جزيلا السيد رئيس اعطي الكلمه الان
الى امين عام حلف شمال الاطلسي السيد يونس
شكرا
انا سعيد ان اعود الى وارسو لالتقى برؤساء
دول وحكومات مجموعه مجموعه بوخاريس
والرئيس بايدن جو اريد ان اقول لك
انني سعيد جدا
لما تقومون بهم الدور الرياضي وزيارتك
لكييف ابعثت بعثت برساله قويه رساله دعم
لاوكرانيا وكذلك التزام
اليات المتحده الذي لا تزعزعت تجاه امني
اوروبا اشكرك ايضا على استضافه قمه النيتو
المقبل بعد قمه يونس في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
عام مدام منذ اطلاق روسيا لغزوها ورئيس
بوتيليس مستعد
للسلام هو يستعد للمزيد من
[موسيقى]
الامين العام ايها الساده والسيدات هكذا
نصل الى ختام هذه الجلسه المفتوحه لوسائل
الاعلام اود ان اطلب منكم التفضل بمغادره
القاعه شكرا